alright folks we're down to the top
three and number three in our top 25
games of 2015 is Metal Gear Solid 5 the
phantom pain
tracking down Scarface you know all the
things Kojima has been building up over
the years with this series sort of
culminated in Metal Gear Solid 5 the
phantom pain I mean there it offers a
gameplay experience that is is so sound
and and that's commendable because there
are so many moving parts that all
interconnect so well together and you
know so many games there there are some
clunky aspects to a mechanic here a
mechanic there and we accept it I
couldn't find them in this game ok
everything felt watertight and refined
with a dash of style at it on top and of
so many systems there's like the
different bodies this is different like
unlocks like so many different tools so
many different weapons so many different
ways to like invade a base and this was
a game where just it was so much fun to
be presented those tools and just kind
of like how about it right Randy yeah
when you talk about that way Danny it's
a super complex game this is something
that you don't get your head around
really quickly but once you do this for
me was the best pure gameplay experience
for me this year you know the fact that
they just basically said here's a
mission here's a base here are all your
tools do it was an amazing experience
for me because it gave you that freedom
to actually approach it any way you
wanted to and also was forgiving enough
to actually let you continue if you did
you something numb and I think that was
one of the the big failings of previous
Metal Gear is in which if it didn't go
wonderful people away you could screw up
an entire mission and have to basically
restart but you know the way that they
put in you know different mechanics can
you make it a lot more accessible I
think was kudos
yeah it's a type of game that even when
you get caught like it's kind of fun
when it all goes to [ __ ] you end up
happen to like explode your way out of
it
and in many ways it's like that series
has always been so well designed like
just perfect stealth action games where
the game does a really good job
communicating to you like something like
stealth is such a difficult thing to try
and communicate to the player we always
feel like it's fair when you get a call
and this is a game that does that but
just blows it out into the scale that
we've never seen before yeah I mean you
have the freedom to you know even back
away and reset a mission right and in
the past that was sort of characterized
by you getting into a locker for
something and keeping it very localized
but in this thing like you know if you
were trying to take this like in a
really realistic approach you could get
on your horse haul ass out of there and
wait for things to calm down and go back
in but then you also have things like
air drops right which some people look
at is maybe a crush but really those
were things that you had to earn and
unlock and develop and the whole mother
based scenario really did make you feel
like you were leading an army and they
were at your command and you know snake
either solid or naked snake or big boss
you know they they were always started
this like lone wolf and this is the
first time where it mean Peace Walker
dabbled with it but this is really the
first time where it felt like yeah I'm
leading this sort of like new frontier
and and this is my army and they're
gonna support me and I've got their
backs as well and I guess on top of the
fact that this is a really mechanically
rich and fun game that so many people
were anticipating it was also a really
good closing - what is one of the most
beloved franchises in modern video games
yeah I don't closing is hard for me to -
I can't really use that word because
this is you know the missing chapter in
the middle of a grand tale a tale that
is filled with holes and retconning and
crazy convoluted characters that don't
make sense to anyone who hasn't gone to
great lengths to understand all these
intricate backstories but you know a lot
of people were hoping for a story that
sort of tie everything together
but I didn't want that why do I want
that I already know where these
characters are going this game did a
wonderful job of resting between
numerous games but still surprising us
at the end I I walked away with respect
for I mean I guess Kojima liked me you
know not said pat him on the back too
much cuz it was a team effort but but if
the story is his and he is known for
subverting expectations and giving us
things that we didn't know we wanted
he's a wonderful job doing that here and
I can't think of a better way for him to
give the game back to the fans as he
walks away from
you